[Musica]
Benvenuti bambini è morto tutto qua oggi
si parla di razzismo c'è stato un
periodo negli anni 90 in cui ogni
singola spalla comica dei film comici
italiani era napoletana Oddio È arrivato
mio marito leporino invece nei film
comici americani quando dovevano
doppiare qualcuno con un accento
particolare come lo doppiavano in
napoletano
e che non vuoi creare un giocattolo
totalmente napoletano Ciro L'orso
napoletano ad alcune avrò aperto la
scatola della memoria ad altri quelli
che non conoscono chi sia Ciro
allacciatevi le cinture Perché state per
partire per un viaggio che nel 2022 non
si potrebbe più fare in tutti questi
viaggi dei Toys Center ancora fatto sono
incappato in una roba terrificante Avete
presente L'allegro chirurgo Quel gioco
dove tu devi estrarre organo per organo
e osso per osso le cose da un povero
paziente senza muovere troppo le mani
altrimenti gli suona il naso qualche
genio luminare del marketing ha detto
sai cosa ci starebbe perfettamente con
L'allegro chirurgo
paw Patrol quel cartone d'animazione 3D
che voi tanto amate Ma che noi trentenni
vediamo ovunque Ma nessuno di noi ha
visto neanche mezza puntata Io mi sono
immaginato una roba dove operi i cani
magari anche se non è proprio bellissimo
per voi bambini operare un cucciolo di
cane poi nella copertina ci c'è la
strada ho detto Magari sistemi tombini
sistemi gli idranti che ne so Fai un po'
l'operatore ecologico che ne so ma
Questo l'ho pensato io piccolo imbecille
che non è il capomastro del reparto
marketing loro hanno pensato di fare una
cosa molto più semplice la vedete la
copertina del gioco Ecco hanno usato la
stessa immagine senza neanche
ridimensionarla mettendo dei buchi a
caso dove puoi estrarre degli oggetti a
caso in due minuti hanno creato
un'immagine e hanno massimizzato la resa
di questo gioco bravo bravissimo Spero
vi abbiano pagato tanto a Natale Mi sto
scaldando già devo stare devo
tranquillizzarmi si parla di razzismo ma
tornando al soggetto del video questo
Ciro l'orsacchiotto napoletano com'è
esattamente quello che vi immaginate è
un orsacchiotto che parla napoletano è
Ciro io non so quante unità abbiano
venduto Ma hanno fatto addirittura tre
versioni l'orsacchiotto normale tra
virgolette
l'orsacchiotto che balla e canta è
quello che suona il mandolino fiamma
fiamma
aiuto chi sei sono morto Finora ti piace
la pizza
e lui parla napoletano
[Applauso]
[Musica]
non c'è bisogno di migliorare la bambina
vi fuori fuori tutti fuori forza forza
fori Ma che hai sta caciara
Ma stai zitta bambini non imitatelo non
imitatemi non fate nulla andate via in
pace basta andatevene tutti sparite
forza fuori tutti
benvenuti in studio per un evento molto
speciale siamo qui in compagnia di due
bambini della scuola elementare santoria
di Santarosa di Torino e Franca Erika di
9 anni e Andrea di 7 Un uccellino mi ha
detto che domani è il tuo compleanno ma
tanti auguri Andrea sarà 8 anni domani
siamo qui tra l'altro se volete giocare
tutto per voi eh Siamo qui per leggere
uno dei temi tratti dal libro Io
speriamo che il me la cavo scritto dal
maestro Marcello D'Orta che ha racchiuso
tutti i temi dei bambini napoletani e
che anche voi arrivate da Posillipo
giusto
esattamente da Posillipo e vorrei legge
quindi uno di questi ovviamente voi Ok
Lo so che è difficile lavorare con i
bambini e so che potreste annoiarvi un
pochino quindi vi faccio un piccolo
regalo
l'8 marzo e la festa della donna
Io penso e credo che la donna deve
essere uguale all'uomo perché non è
giusto che non è uguale
l'8 marzo la donna deve essere uguale
all'uomo
in quel giorno l'ingenuità dei bambini
No in quel giorno tutti gli uomini
portano le mimose alle donne e anche
altri uomini però io conosco un uomo che
l'otto marzo ha una donna gli diede un
calcio
me lo ha raccontato mio padre
sei leggibile
mio padre Porta i tram adesso ma una
volta faceva il pompiere c'è qualcosa
che non sta quadrando vero Allora
accadde che una donna dell'8 Marzo si
voleva buttare giù dal tetto e
chiamarono i pompieri giustamente mio
padre era quello che saliva sulle case
per non far Gettare la gente dai palazzi
bello bello lui salì e quando si trovò
faccia a faccia con la pazza le disse Ma
tu perché ti vuoi buttare per farci
passare un guaio a noi
Allora quella un poco Ci pensò ancora se
si voleva buttare o ritornare nel
salotto e penso di buttarsi ma anche mio
padre si buttò su di lei e l'ha preso
normale quando scesero giù un amico di
mio padre che era pompiere maggiù diede
un calcio alla pazza per la paura che se
era preso io se ero quel signore il
calcio non glielo davo quel giorno che
era l'8 marzo un altro giorno sì ma che
cos'è ecco qua ecco qua l'ingenuità dei
bambini una grande risata da Napoli Io
ringrazio i bambini Erick e Andrea e
Andrea è ancora tanti auguri per il tuo
compleanno Grazie ai tuoi genitori che
mi hanno detto di Scotti Sì stavo
leggendo un regalo Ecco qui Grazie mille
per essere passati e noi ci vediamo ad
un prossimo sketch Grazie mille wow wow
Vi auguro
L'orso Ciro scatolato che è Una rarità
di 'sti tempi trovare un gioco usato
scatolatolato
c'è il Vesuvio sulla cravatta
c'è il sole c'è Il mare c'è una piccola
piccola barca a vela direi che abbiamo
tutto per iniziare ma la cosa bella
guardandolo così è che Ciro e l'orso che
parla ma la scatola intrattiene forse
più di lui è una roba assurda c'è di
tutto Allora prima cosa fra tutte
abbonati al servizio gli sms inviando al
48-484 il testo di PS Ciro per ricevere
in esclusiva le frasi di Ciro le frasi
in ante cioè tutti gli iscrivervi ad un
servizio a pagamento per avere in
anteprima delle frasi che lui non dice o
chi dice non sto capendo niente la voce
di Ciro è di Claudio d'esposito ma
Claudio d'esposito l'attivista del WWF
sarebbe incredibile che è un attivista
del WWF abbia dato la voce ad un orso
Non so se si legge bene ma c'è scritto
che ogni messaggio al servizio sono
12,40 e per ogni contenuto ricevuto
credo siano le frasi di Ciro 3 euro 3
euro iva inclusa a settimana ma che
cazzo dici questa cosa non potevano
farla più stereotipata di così Ciro in
vespa una vespa rossa in un vicolo di
Napoli pieno di spazzatura c'è una
buccia di banana una lattina il bidone
foglie cartacee le scritte sul muro le
croste i panni appesi
senza casco non mi manca anche la voce
non mi fa ridere così tanto per una
scatola Ciro ho trovato il mandolino ho
trovato il chitarretto quello piccolino
apriamolo Per l'amor del Signore però è
bello però è morbido tocca morbidissimo
ce l'avevi
Ma che dici dietro dovrebbe avere il
portapile
[Risate]
c'è un pulsante
Yam guagliù
nella scatola c'è scritto che si può
mettere a testa sotto
Ti prego ti prego tra i tassi c'è anche
la pancia
Grazie mille lo faccio di lavoro tra
l'altro ci sono proprio dei piccoli
pulsanti che effettuano sotto le il
palmo delle sue zampine
È incredibile tanto dovrebbe parlare
anche quando parli tu quindi se io lo
tengo seduto Ciro mi senti
Ciro
Ciro mi senti Mi senti non funziona
questa funzione c'è anche scritta sulla
scatola ogni volta che sente parlare o
sento un rumore dice una frase
divertente
io mi ricordo che c'era un altro
giocattolo napoletano che era
Cicciobello Napoletano cioè proprio ho
nella mia memoria impressa la pubblicità
che passava nei canali forse regionali
per Cicciobello Napoletano E addirittura
mi ricordo che non solo c'è la
pubblicità Ma che era stata tradotta la
pubblicità originale era in napoletano e
poi era stata ridoppiata in italiano
perché non lo so Ué lo sapete
Cicciobello tifa Napoli
io lo vorrei trovare da qualche parte
amici appello ai napoletani se qualcuno
acquista memoria fatemelo sapere perché
altrimenti sono pazza
ha sentito questa funzione Purtroppo è
un po' così così ma credo abbia dei
problemi al microfono Però funziona ed è
di una qualità che sinceramente non mi
aspettavo e morbidissimo si può
pettinare in tutti i modi che vuoi e
ogni singolo tasto funziona forse mi è
andata di fortuna che sono riuscito a
trovare un Ciro usato perfettamente
funzionante se non il volume un po'
bassino
è molto molto basso la prossima volta
che scendo a Napoli Cerco il mio
Perfetto Così li facciamo parlare tra di
loro
[Musica]
vedi Ciro c'è scritto qua sotto la M
mariuolo ladro o disonesto Perché dai
marioli Bisogna proteggersi ma anche il
computer ha bisogno di protezione con
noi se tu parti per le Hawaii per
esempio Ma vuoi connetterti ad un IP
italiano per guardare Telecapri lo puoi
fare tu sei sulla Circumvesuviana e voi
connetterti ad una rete pubblica ma vuoi
evitare che i tuoi dati vengano
compromessi puoi fare anche quello
malware pop up invasivi se tu attivi la
trait Protection Sei al sicuro anche da
quelle rotture di maroni
anche io e con il codice sconto Yotobi
in descrizione potrete accedere a tutte
le promozioni
non adesso mi sembra esagerato
[Musica]